so listen while i have you
what what should i be doing on twitch
i'm trying to
keep growing and revitalizing on twitch
and i just don't really
you know i i'm thinking of what i want
the right twitch strategy and you seem
to be a good person to go to for that
well right now holy [ __ ] david right now
the twitch meta is actually chess
maybe i should run another tournament
would you play in it if i did maybe i'd
consider it you know you would consider
it yeah i would i think i would
all right yeah i think next week is
going to be
chess on twitch for me
and are all 16 players have been
announced right yes they
we yeah i announced them earlier on the
stream most had already been announced
but the last two were announced on
stephen kenneth destiny bennell the
second would be an interesting player
in the tournament uh yeah i mean i like
i feel like your
politics and the way you explain things
is a little bit better honestly
really oh my god clip that jeez holy
[ __ ] we've got to clip that
that's shocking last thing before we
move on have you taken a position
on the david pakman versus sam cedar
race to a million youtube subscribers or
are you abstaining from that
interesting well i haven't even heard
about this so i don't have a take on it
yet
it stirred up the progressive media
space dramatically my hot take
is that if you're botting it would show
in your engagement levels and it
probably isn't
so all right well good i feel like i
think i had a cold take though i'm sorry
i
could have been a little bit more spicy
i'll i'll think about it and send you
well you don't
okay let's look at a few different uh
things elements that i have to play for
you
there was a very ugly moment the other
day with stephen
kenneth destiny bonnell ii and one of my
chess coaches alexandra botez
you tell me what you make of this this
seems like there's a little bit of i
don't know if we would call it
jealousy or envy but something seems a
little weird take a look at this
but hey listen i hope you have fun i
hope you have fun with your new best
friend david pakman
playing in pogchamps okay i hope you
guys uh have a great time over there and
i'll just be over here getting dumped
by my fiance you [ __ ] [ __ ]
that's pretty aggressive um i didn't
like i i don't like how destiny
he seems rattled and on tilt quite
frankly by the fact that alexander has
been coaching me
it's weird it's weird and i'm gonna have
to probably get a hold of him and see if
we can clear some of that up because
that's a very
i don't want things going in that
direction with stephen
and um you know i just think we have to
be very very careful there
okay so we've got that other memes let's
see if i can put these up on the screen
yeah here we go
let me see there we go so this i
received
me trying to understand david pakman's
discount